hallo und herzlich willkommen tsum heute
plus live stream unserer corona
sprechstunde die ganze woche beantworten
wir eure und ihre fragen zur epidemie
aber heute wollen wir uns nicht mit den
wirklichen fakten des virus beschäftigen
sondern mit den falschen mit den ganzen
falschmeldungen den fake news und auch
den verschwörungstheorien die gibt es ja
quasi immer sobald was größeres passiert
auf der welt dass dort auf einmal
merkwürdige videos auftauchen dubioser
artikeln aus quellen die man nicht so
richtig kennt die häufig auch ein
bisschen dubios aussehen und die geben
dann immer an nur sie würden die
wirklich richtige wahrheit kennen die
die mainstream-medien sprich wir hier
unter drücken würden
wir wollen darüber heute mit andré wolf
sprechender es fakt checker bei einer
website namens mini kamera punkt at die
kommt aus österreich
und die hat sich quasi nur diese aufgabe
verschieden solche sachen zu enttarnen
und aufzuklären über feld - und
verschwörungstheorien fragen zu diesen
ganzen komplex also bitte nicht zum
virus uns zu den maßnahmen sondern nur
zur verschwörungstheorien und
merkwürdigen meldungen bitte in die
kommentare ich guck dass ich die
mitnehme aber jetzt erst mal hallo andré
nach wien
hallo grüß gott und guten abend
vielleicht erstmal für alle die eure
seite noch nicht kennen mini-kamera
punkt at was macht ihr genau der verein
minicar ist ein verein gegen internet
missbraucht das heißt uns gibt es schon
seit dem jahr 2011 und wir klären ja
falschmeldungen auch wir helfen
nutzerinnen und nutzern auf social media
wir gehen halt allen inhalten hinterher
die ja probleme bereiten auch social
media das interessante ist oder wo was
wir halt anders machen als andere
redaktion wir arbeiten auf nutzer ebene
das heisst man kann uns anfragen zu
senden
wir schauen uns dann an was dahinter
steckt und beantworten das ganze dann
also es muss nicht unbedingt sein dass
wir jetzt hier die großen investigative
recherchen machen sondern es sind auch
teilweise einfache kettenbriefe die man
uns senden kann
wir gucken was steckt dahinter wir
klären dann auf behelfen
neben den social media falschmeldung und
mythen die unterwegs sind schicken wir
auch das internet nach nach viren nach
spam nach trojanern dementsprechend
können wir auch immer genau gucken was
aktuell an cyberkriminellen sachen
unterwegs ist das ist doch unsere
aufgabe was wir jetzt wirklich machen
seit über neun jahren machen die größte
teil der größte teil der arbeit ist
ehrenamtlich das heißt unser team
besteht zu 95 prozent aus ehrenamtlichen
hier in wien hauptamtliche sind der
gründe das war einst omas wannenmacher
und ich und wir arbeiten halt rund um
die uhr auf social media und sind halt
da wenn wir uns jetzt nur mal diesen
teil eurer arbeit angucken der sich mit
fake news mit falschen
tatsachenbehauptungen und mit
verschwörungstheorien beschäftigt jetzt
ganz einfach gefragt was ist daran so
gefährlich also ich habe hier eine frage
bekommen auf ins tor von tim der meinte
warum soll man sich nicht aus
verschiedenen quellen informieren und
sich selber eine meinung bildet egal von
wem sie kommt und wer das sagt der
ansatz ist natürlich grundsätzlich nicht
verkehrt dass man sich verschiedene
quellen anschaut und sich natürlich eine
meinung bildet wir reden davon
vergleichen der arbeit so genannter
synaptische arbeit
das problem ist nur wenn man dabei
quellen mit einbezieht die eben nicht
richtig sind die bewusst falsch sind die
bewusst tendenziös bericht erstatten
dann kann man dieses bild kriegen dass
die meinung in der mitte liegt die
wahrheit in der mitte liegen würde
was dann jedoch nicht stimmen denn etwas
was falsch ist grundsätzlich falsch ist
kann nicht irgendwo in der mitte basiert
sein das ist das problem
dementsprechend muss ich wenn ich lese
die ich nicht kenne natürlich auch immer
prüfen ob das stimmt was dort steht oder
zumindest einen kleinen faktencheck
ansätzen wie sind diese quellen
aufgebaut sind die seriös sind die vor
einem transparent das ist immer etwas
ganz wichtiges
transparenz ist etwas was sehr häufig
mit seriosität eingeht das heißt ich
schaue auf eine webseite ein impressum
vorhanden ist auch beim youtube kanal
auf einem presse von ist ein realer
ansprechperson eine wirklich einer
da wo ich meine anfragen hinrichten
hinschicken kann wenn ich das nicht habe
habe ich immer ein problem denn das aus
einer anonymen intransparenten situation
lässt es sich natürlich viel leichter
unwahrheiten zu verbreiten oder etwas zu
verbreiten was manipuliert ist oder
desinformation letztendlich zu
verbreiten wir gucken uns gleich noch
mal ganz genau an was man als nutzer
machen kann das ist ja teilweise gar
nicht mal so einfach das zu checken
aber vielleicht müssen wir erstmal genau
erklären was so der unterschied ist weil
fake news und verschwörungstheorien sind
ja doch zwei verschiedene seiten quasi
von einem selben phänomen
fangen wir mal mit fake news an das ist
glaube ich dass etwas einfachere
phänomen wie würdest du fake news
definieren und woran erkennt man die es
in wirklichkeit ist das sogar dass das
spiel der schwierigere begriff den
begriff fake news haben wir bis donald
trump ja gar nicht angewendet im
deutschsprachigen raum
er kam ja wirklich erst durch trump in
denen er sich hinstellt und das ganze
als politischen kampfbegriff benutzer
dem us trio a fake news und das war halt
das problem dann haben wir auf einmal
diesen begriff gab den es zu
differenzieren ging was sind fake news
letztendlich und da geht es halt einmal
darum fake news sind sind nachrichten
die sich der partizipativen kulturen von
social media bedienen die als also
darauf ausgelegt sind dass sie geteilt
werden sollen und in zweiter linie geht
es beim fake news darum dass sie bewusst
hergestellt werden das heißt sieht man
betreiben bewusst desinformation bewusst
manipulation sie sind bewusst erfundene
geschichten teilweise dann kommt es
immer darauf an mit welcher intention
manche fake news sind halt aus
wirtschaftlichen gründen in die welt
gesetzt werden dass man jemanden
überreden will ein bestimmtes system
einzusteigen irgendwie zu spekulieren
oder zu investieren und dann gibt es
natürlich die manipulativen fake die uns
die natürlich auch politisch genutzt
werden
demgegenüber stehen natürlich die
verschwörungs mythen die jetzt schon
immer schon länger da sind die die
wirklich auch ein fester bestandteil der
der narrativen kultur ist das noch lange
aktiv
eingebettet sind nochmal lassen uns da
nicht noch mal eingreifen erst einmal
den fake news bleiben heute bei den
bewussten oder vielleicht teilweise auch
das weiß ich manchmal auch nicht
vielleicht unbewusst hergestellten
falsch nachrichten wir haben da mal ein
beispiel weil es gibt einen youtuber den
nenne ich jetzt mal nur coach zieht um
ihn nicht zu vielen fällen zu geben der
sich mit vielen videos mit dem corona
virus beschäftigt und der hat zum
beispiel folgende behauptung hier
aufgestellt und jetzt kommen wir zu dem
bericht vom robert-koch-institut
natürlich verlinkt ich euch alles das
sind alles informationen die ich direkt
vom robert koch institut selbst habe wie
die bestimmung wann fällst du in die
statistik wann bist du ein chor wird
infizierter und das kannst du dir hier
durchlesen und jetzt gibt es hier eine
zusatzinformation weil man hat gesehen
die tage davor sind die fallzahlen nicht
mehr richtig hoch gegangen um da wieder
richtig schwung reinzubringen das ganze
damit die zahlen auch schön explodieren
hat man sich da jetzt folgendes
einfallen lassen und zwar kontakt zu
einem bestätigten fall ist definiert als
vorliegen von mindestens einen der
beiden folgenden kriterien innerhalb der
letzten 14 tage vor erkrankungsbeginn
also zum einen versorgung
beziehungsweise pflege einer person
insbesondere durch medizinisches
personal oder familienmitglieder oder
aufenthalt am selben ort zb
klassenzimmer arbeitszimmer wohnung
haushalt erweiterter familien
kreiskrankenhaus andere
wohneinrichtungen kaserne oder
ferienlager wie eine person während
diese symptomatisch war
übersetzt heißt das wenn du im raum mit
irgendjemand warst der den corona virus
die neue form hat und genießt hat zum
beispiel dann fällst du automatisch auch
in die statistik mit rein obwohl du gar
nicht getestet wurde ist und es
überhaupt gar nicht nachweisbar ist dass
du es überhaupt hast also es reicht
alleine schon wenn jemand im raum es
hatte einmal genießt hat oder symptome
hatte und dann werden gleich alle mit
reingenommen die statistik
soweit ein ausschnitt aus diesem video
mal als beispiel das klingt natürlich
total krass wir haben dann beim
robert-koch-institut mal nachgefragt und
haben mit der pressestelle telefoniert
und die haben uns gesagt was er dort
behauptet ist schlichtweg falsch weil es
dass das gegenteil der fall
die kontakt definition findet sich dort
in der stelle im dokument sogar deswegen
um sie genau abzugrenzen von dem was als
corona fall gilt also hat das quasi
verdreht so jetzt ist dann natürlich die
frage
andré meinst du dass es tatsächlich kann
man einmal sagen dass das absicht oder
hat er einfach jemand ein großes
unwissen an den tag gelegt und sachen
falsch verstanden
da geht es natürlich auch immer zu
gucken will was sind das für quellen in
welcher intention handeln die natürlich
gibt es dieses phänomen dass jemand
etwas falsch versteht falsch weitergibt
und das ganze geschieht unbewusst das
haben wir häufig parketten briefen dass
man halt eine situation falsch
beobachtet oder beobachtet und sie
fallen schweiz erreicht das typische
stille post phänomen
dann gibt es auf der anderen seite
natürlich auch die bewussten und da sind
wir wieder in dem fake news bereich die
bewussten manipulation und bewusste
desinformation das heißt jemand nutzt
eine quelle kennt schon vorher die
intentionen die man gehen möchte und
nutzt diese quelle zum eigenen vorteil
in eine bestimmte richtung auch aus und
da spielt es dann keine rolle was die
quelle wirklich sagt sondern da geht es
einfach nur um die eigene manipulation
da wird dann auch gar nicht weiter eine
rückfrage gehalten in diesem fall wäre
es natürlich spannend gewesen wenn in
dem video gesagt wurde okay wir haben
mit dem robert-koch-institut auch
telefoniert oder ich hätte das getan und
die haben mir das erklärt sondern es
gibt eine rein eigene interpretation die
erstmal über das gestellt wird was
vielleicht dahinter stehen würde
das passiert das natürlich das passiert
recht häufig und das sind dann wirklich
die bereiche von fake news wo jemand
etwas bewusst macht und den das muss man
dann halt abgrenzen gegenüber dem was er
unbewusst passiert wo man einfach noch
etwas beobachteten kein schweizer gibt
so jetzt kommen hier in den kommentaren
kritiker die sagen hier zum beispiel wir
können mal auf meinen rechner schalten
auf youtube ein user namens sie genio
der sagt als ob medien keine geschichten
erfinden ich sag nur lucius so das war
ja der spiegel reporter der tatsächlich
sachen erfunden hat
die es nicht gab und dann gab es ja auch
eine frage ich gucke noch mal kurz wo
sie war auf twitter von direktors 123
sind nicht alle publikations quellen
tendenziös also irgendwo haben sie nicht
alle irgendwo eine intention etwas zu
bewegen oder etwas zu nutzen so wie
grenzt man das denn jetzt ab zwei
wunderbare fragen dieses reduziert
problem dass das das wird immer wieder
angeführt ganz klar natürlich hat er
geschichten erfunden das spannender was
hierbei immer unterschlagen wird ist
dass der spiegel die geschichte selber
aufgedeckt hat das heißt es hat eine
eigene korrektur stattgefunden und das
ist immer ganz wichtig medien die sich
selbst korrigieren die wirklich am
nächsten tag auch sagen hier wir haben
einen fehler entdeckt in unserer
berichterstattung das möchten wir
korrigieren wir zeigen euch dass das ist
immer ein qualitätsmerkmal eine
selbstkorrektur
das hat beim spiegel natürlich
stattgefunden das ist ganz klar sie
gehen sie sind mit der geschichte offen
umgegangen wenn man jetzt natürlich sagt
das dass das reh lucius für alle stehen
würden für alle medien ist natürlich
quatsch
dann wäre diese selbstkorrektur auch gar
nicht gewesen die zweite frage geben um
die frage ob berichterstattung nicht
immer irgendwie tendenziös dass ich sie
auch mal bestimmten richtung kommt oder
bestimmte argumente stärker gewichtet
als andere ganz klar da sind wir in dem
bereich auch das fleming's wo ich immer
sagt man kann nicht nicht frame ja
grundsätzlich hat jede geschichte immer
irgendwo eine richtung die man vorgibt
die frage ist nur wie stark
ja das kann man ganz klar erkennen es
gibt blogs und webseiten speziell auch
anonym betrieben blogs und webseiten die
extrem früh wenn die extreme in eine
richtung mit starken worten drücken und
dann gibt es eine nach möglichkeit so
objektive berichterstattung wie möglich
geben so wenig wie möglich fremd aber
natürlich muss man wissen dass irgendwo
bestimmte redaktions linien immer
irgendwo existieren das immer irgendwo
leitsätze existieren ganz klar das ist
normal
nur die frage ist wie stark sind die
ausgeprägt die sind halt an einigen
stellen wesentlich schwächer ausgeprägt
und an anderen stellen extrem und das
muss man halt erkennen das erkennt man
dann häufig halt
fremming begriffen oder wie stark
negative eingesetzt werden und dann kann
man halt dann weiß man halt in welche
richtung es geht das als beispiel für
ein fremming weil viele kennen den
begriff ja auch nur so im vorbeigehen
wenn jetzt zum beispiel einen blog
schreibt von menschen die aus
kriegsgebieten flüchten das sind
asylanten das ist noch ein weicher frame
im begriff oder das sind
sozialschmarotzer dann weiß man da kommt
er aus einer rechten hacke und wenn dort
geflüchtete steht dann weiß man dass er
aus der linken ecke wahrscheinlich ne
genau es geht wirklich welche wortwahl
ist ein tatsächliches report auch
goldstücke wird jan im umfang auch gerne
mal genannt oder mehr genannten das sind
wirklich ganz starke vorherigen begriffe
und da weiß ich jemand will schon allein
mit dem begriff in meinem kopf ein bild
aufbauen dass ich gleich schon eine
meinung kann und eine seriöse
berichterstattung versucht eben das zu
vermeiden und wirklich so schwache
begriffe wie möglich zu nutzen so wir
sind das aber bei corona natürlich und
wir haben jetzt macht fake news abzug
abzugrenzen zu framingham es ist schon
manchmal wirklich schwierig
verschwörungstheorien sind ja noch mal
die heftigere variante von fremming
würde ich sagen bzw verschwörungs mythen
hast du auch gerade schon gesagt auch da
haben wir mal ein beispiel rausgesucht
von einem herrn namens cannot ich sie
bleibende angst vor der vor dieser
unmittelbaren gefahr früher oder lange
zeit auch in der jüngsten vergangenheit
war es ja die russen und dann kann der
tourismus und dann kam die russen um die
terrorismus aber jetzt ist die gewalt
viel schlimmer das ist der virus das ist
kona das ist unsichtbar und deswegen man
kann sich überall anstecken und deswegen
muss man vorsichtig sein und ich habe
mir vor allem überlegt wenn erich
honecker zum beispiel ja wenn er gewollt
hätte dass die mauer länger stehenbleibt
hätte bewusst dass mit der mit der mit
alkohol haben müssen jede diktatur auch
adolf hitler hätte das nur mit der krone
haben müssen
die hat nur sagen müssen nur zu
demonstration wie schließt euch an geht
im moment nie wegen alkohol virus um
leute zu hause geblieben
so das sind natürlich jetzt auch relativ
starke parallelen gezogen werden
woran ist das ist das so ein klassisches
ding das da so parallelen zu diktaturen
gezogen werden zum beispiel oder woran
erkennt man überhaupt jetzt eine
verschwörungstheorie der begriff ist
auch schwierig denn neben dem
auseinandernehmen jetzt einfach mal da
müssen jetzt nicht diese parallelen zu
diktaturen seien das ist eher untypisch
gewesen
typischerweise hat man es dann immer mit
irgendwelchen narrativen also mit
erzählt strukturen zu tun die man schon
kennt die einem irgendwie bekannt sind
und dadurch dass die an bekannt sind ist
man der ansicht dass sie dass sie
stimmen weil man sich wohlfühlt in der
erzählstruktur weil weil man sich schon
immer gehört hat dass ich gehe jetzt mal
so ein bisschen vom corona weg ich gehe
mal auf 2014 zurück da hatten wir eine
große geschichte die idee da ist es
weiße lieferwagen fahren durch
deutschland würden kleine kinder
entführen und sie nach bulgarien bringen
um dort deren organe zu enden so da drin
steckt ein world is narrativ nämlich das
sogenannte [ __ ] narrativ dieses
osteuropa weißer lieferwagen
das ist eine geschichte die man voraus
kleinster kindheit schon kennt irgendwo
oder vermeintlich kennt was heißt
vorsichtig auf die straße da sind
[ __ ] die würden dich entführen
das wurde 2014 noch mal digital verpackt
und ging ging unheimlich viral die
geschichte war glaubwürdig wegen des
tiefs letztendlich obwohl sie völliger
quatsch ist also irgendwo oder
grundsätzlich ist die völliger quatsch
aber halt weil die geschichte die
erzählstruktur irgendwie im kopf hängen
bleibt wirkt es so plausibel und das ist
das gefährliche an negativen wenn sie
darüber per schöpfungsmythen mit
eingebaut werden
1 was mir immer wieder begegnet ist so
dieses eine gruppe von mächtigen
versucht etwas durchzusetzen und uns zu
manipulieren um sich selbst zu
bereichern das habe ich jetzt auch bei
corona häufiger gefunden ist das auch so
eins von diesem grund negativen uralte
geschichte die hunderte von jahren alt
ist das ist das welt judentum das
sogenannte das ist wirklich eine
geschichte mehr 100 jahre alt ist die
immer wieder übertragen wurde immer
wieder neu aufgelegt wurde und die jetzt
wieder da
ist ja ganz klar heißt das jetzt auch
wieder da kommt auf einmal die
geschichte von von george soros und und
rothschild wieder ins spiel die dahinter
stecken würden bund und bill gates wäre
auch noch mit drinnen das heißt wir
hätten auf einmal eine finanzierte und
dann einen welt judentum was hin
dahinter stecken würde das ist nur eins
der vielen verschwörungs mythen oder dem
moment unterwegs sind aber die bedienen
sich genau dieser erzählstruktur die
nicht neu ist die immer da war
und irgendwo im kopf hängt das ist halt
das problem all diesen medien
wir haben jetzt hier eine frage von
alice kabel oder carol auf youtube die
möchte wissen wer entscheidet jetzt
eigentlich war es eine
verschwörungstheorie oder fake news ist
gibt es auch keine konferenz kilo seien
keine kriterien ja da gibt es da keine
kriterien das macht man anhand von von
narrativen von erzählweisen fest das
macht man daran fest ob etwas wirklich
ja in diesen verschwörungs charakter hat
deswegen rege sich ja von mythen und ich
von theorien eine theorie ist ja etwas
was beweist so ein mythos ist ja nicht
beweisbar aber die versuchen hast du
immer zu beweisen mit fakten
es sind ja in dem sinne keine fakten es
sind untermalungen die die sich dann
dementsprechend auch teilweise
widerlegen lassen nein ein wunderbare
erklärt oder ein wunderbarer erklären
mythos wieso verschwörungs mythen
funktionieren ist ja die bielefeld
verschwörung de ist ja wirklich
absichtlich so erschaffen und zu zeigen
wie verschwörungs mythen funktionieren
dass man für alles immer eine einfache
erklärung hat und wenn man das ganze
wieder legen will ist nur ein teil der
ganzen geschichte das heißt jeder der
sagt bielefeldt existiert doch ist weil
man ja da war heißt es ja definitiv
wurden
brainwash also die da waren da wurde das
gehirn gewaschen und deswegen glauben
sie dass jetzt das ist eine wunderbare
flasche ein wunderbarer verschwörungs
mythos oben andere verschwörungs mythen
zu erklären jetzt habe ich gerade schon
gesagt der begriff verschwörungstheorie
du hast ja noch benutzt ihn nicht so
dass verschwörungs mythen der wird auch
politisch genutzt teilweise hier ist
eine frage von petra es auf youtube
verso wir hatten kritisch und
selbstständig denkende menschen die
fragen stellen sofort als
verschwörungstheoretiker beschimpft
anstatt diese fragen einfach sachlich zu
beantworten
das ist jetzt die frage wo man sich wo
man sich um gibt ja also beleidigungen
sind natürlich grundsätzlich fehl am
platz nur das problem ist man muss es
sich auch erklären lassen dürfen ja wenn
ich jetzt wenn jetzt hier werden mit
einem verschwörungs mythos ankommt und
jemand anderes kommt und kann das
eindeutig faktisch wieder legen dann
geht es natürlich auch darum um den see
erzählstruktur wie verhalten sich die
beiden sagte eine am ende
ok ja du hast recht ich habe gerade
gemerkt das ist quatsch sagt der andere
auf einmal du gehörst doch dazu zu den
verschwörern und daran merkt man dann
auch wieder den bereich der
verschwörungs mythen ganz interessante
ist ja dass viele von diesen videos die
jetzt mit merkwürdigen mythen oder
theorien um sich werfen immer sagen sie
sind keine verschwörungstheoretiker auch
dann noch mal ein beispiel wieder aus
dem video von coach c du darfst dieses
video aufnehmen und du darfst es
irgendwo auf youtube oder irgendwo
teilen vervielfältigen und so weiter und
so fort warum weil da draußen eine
zensur passiert also wir sind schon
dabei unsere demokratie zu verlieren
also sogar ärzten die jahrelange
erfahrung haben den werden die videos
gesperrt
das ist unglaublich also man darf
praktisch in diesem fall nicht mehr
seine eigene meinung sein und deswegen
gebe ich dir erlaubnis du solltest es
sofort teilen und auch aufnehmen dass
wenn dieses video auch verschwindet wie
andere videos auch dann hast du es
so habe ich einen fehler gemacht dass
die selbstkorrektur das war das video
das ist uns auch dass sein dass solche
videos immer wieder sagen man muss sie
teilen man muss sie weiter verbreitet
weil sie werden ja und verdrückt ist das
auch so ein klassisches merkmal das ist
ein ganz klares selbst legitimierung
hier geht es wirklich darum dass man
meint oder das video selbst zu einer art
mythos stilisiert zu einem opfer
stilisiert falls es gelöscht wird habe
ich ja die wahrheit gesagt das kommt
dahinter raus ist die erzählweise
das interessante ist es wird ja da gar
nichts in wirklichkeit gelöscht wenn man
halt eine meinung sagt oder selbst wenn
man ein verschwörungs mythos aufstellt
wird ist ja nicht gelöscht gelöscht wird
ja meistens nur wenn ein
urheberrechtlich relevante inhalt drin
ist das heißt wenn jetzt diese person
was von zdf abgefilmt hätte und dass
wieder neue hochgeladen hätte und
behauptet das wird jetzt gelöscht weil
ich das und das nicht zeigen darf dann
liegt im höchstfall daran war das zdf
die urheberrechte daran hat uns das
nicht möchte als beispiel jens gesagt
und es kann auch jeder andere sein
das sind die gründe warum etwas
verschwindet oder wenn es halt gegen die
regeln der plattform verspricht und
diese rege spricht und dass die sind
meister festgeschrieben wenn es gegen
gewalt pornografie oder ähnliches dann
werden ja gelöscht aber nicht weil
jemand seine meinung sagt und die nach
eigenen aussagen kritisch sein könnte
über die plattform sprechen wir gleich
nochmal jetzt möchte ich aber doch noch
mal dass gutes beispiel zeigen dass in
vielen dieser videos neben diesen aufruf
dass man sie teilen soll weil sie werden
ja vielleicht zensiert häufig darauf
referiert wird dass gesagt wird also wir
sind alles noch fakten ist keine
verschwörungstheorie
können wirklich 33 millionen menschen am
corona virus sterben
bill gates hat vor einem jahr
vorausgesagt dass eine pandemie kommen
könnte mit einem virus der in china
startet und da könnten 33 menschenleben
bei zugrunde gehen und da müssen wir
heute einfach drüber sprechen
so auch in diesem video steht
tatsächlich im titel untendrunter fakten
keine verschwörung gibt es mittlerweile
also einen besseren begriff für dieses
phänomen dass man das nicht als
verschwörungstheorie bezeichnet du hast
verschwörungs mythos gesagt gibt noch
etwas anderes wie man die man dazu sagen
kann ebenso um diesen kampfbegriff
aufzuweichen
grundsätzlich ja also ich habe mit
vielen menschen schon gesprochen die
auch in dem bereich tätig sind und die
sprechen tatsächlich nicht mehr mit dem
begriff theorie weil deine theorie ja
etwas ist etwas wissenschaftliches ist
und deswegen gibt es da ja ein
verschwörungs geschichten oder ähnlich
also es ist natürlich auch ein frame ihn
letztendlich denn denn hier wird auch
die richtung wie schon gesagt in welche
was es geht deswegen spreche ich
beispielsweise generell nur noch vom
verschwörungs mythen weil es ist ein
mythos wenn jemand wirklich
interpretiert irgendwo und geschichten
davon erzählt die letztendlich faktisch
nicht beweisbar sind ist es ein mythos
und wenn sie dann tradiert werden also
weiter gereicht werden entwickelt sich
dieser mythos halt weiter im ansprechend
hier gibt es auch eine frage woher
wissen wir dass die quellen bewusst
falsch sind beziehungsweise diese quelle
die ja gerade referiert hat also bill
gates hat das gesagt mit den 33
millionen infizierten das war aber
innerhalb einer alles völlig anderen
kontext wie kann man das denn jetzt
belegen also das ist ja schwierig weil
er taucht teilweise wirklich sachen aus
der wirklichkeit genommen werden
die man dann wieder findet das ist
tatsächlich leider nicht so einfach das
heißt man muss nicht immer darf nicht
immer nur diesen einzelnen satz sehen
sondern muss genau wirklich das lesen wo
das ganze heer
den kontext verstehen hier geht es
wirklich darum dass man nicht immer nur
schlagzeilen liest oder einzeln schlag
begriff aus seinem inhalt nimmt sondern
wirklich einen gesamten quelle auch sinn
ergreifend liest und wenn man das dann
tut können würde man in diesen versen
warum billetts das behauptet hat und
dass das hier gar nicht zu passt das
wäre so beispielsweise an wird wenn ihr
mit 1 1 ein film nimmt und dort nur
einen satz raus nimmt und dann behauptet
das ist die kernaussage des films obwohl
der satz zufällig da nur gesagt wurde
der film geht um was ganz anderes
wir haben verschiedene sachen auch im
bereich des chors gesehen es gibt diese
behauptung dass 1981 des corona virus
schon vorher gesehen wurde und dann in
einem buch das ganz genau beschrieben
wurde
nein das stimmt nicht der sg auf seite
39 dieses buches steht einmal was von
einem virus und das ist nur eine ganz
ganz landläufige geschichte in dem buch
es geht auch etwas völlig anderes aber
das ist halt wenn man nicht sinn
ergreifend ließ und genau die quelle
anschaut dann kann man natürlich mit
einzelnen mitteln etwas tendenziös ganz
anders darstellen
eine frage die uns viele menschen
gestellt haben ich nehme jetzt mal
exemplarisch an die usb jahren auf
youtube mal gucken ob ich den kommentar
jetzt auch hier finde da nicht nur dann
machen wir das so
sie wollen alle wissen wie geht man mit
freunden um die verschwörungstheorien
für wahr halten und dann diese sachen
weiterleiten
und er meint jetzt nicht zeigte die
hardcore nervigen sondern eher noch
empathische freunde die emotional eher
etwas verirrt sind was macht man so
etwas machen wir wichtige
differenzierung um was geht es geht
tatsächlich gibt es einmal die die schon
rhein gekippt sind auf der anderen seite
das ist im moment sehr häufig der fall
weil wir in der situation mit dem corona
virus gerne auch informationen haben
wollen diverse situationen auch
verändert haben wollen ist es wichtig
dass man die leute die unwissend
verschwörungs mythen verbreiten
freundlich darauf anspricht das ist der
ganz wichtigen punkt ja das ganze hört
ja irgendwann auch davon gehen wir
zumindest aus und wir wollen ja alle
vernünftig weiter zusammen leben und
weiterhin freunde bleiben also ist es
ganz wichtig ein freundliches feedback
nach
ich kite auf einem privaten kanal zu
geben das heißt dann sollte über private
nachrichten oder beim messenger in einer
eins-zu-eins-situation kurz an sprechen
du warst du mir da geschickt hast finde
ich jetzt nicht so toll aus den und den
gründen bitte schickt mir solche sachen
in zukunft nicht mehr die faktisch nicht
belegbar sind und überlegt selbst ob du
damit etwas gutes tust wenn du das
anderen leuten verschickt also wirklich
freundlich bleiben nicht schimpfen das
ist das allerschlimmste dass man da
jemanden ausgrenzt das funktioniert gar
nicht sondern wirklich das freundliche
gespräch suchen und ein freundliches
feedback geben aber schwierig wird das
ja das ist mir gestern aufgefallen wenn
das auf einmal große influenza sind mit
einer halben million follower die anfang
diese videos zu teilen und zu sagen hier
guckt euch das mal an ich wollte euch
das zeigen da wird euch was verschwiegen
kann man das wirklich noch freundlich
bleiben da kommt es ja wirklich darauf
immer immer darauf an wo man sich
befindet sind es wirklich freunde die
mir das in deiner 121 kommunikation
geschickt haben oder sind das wirklich
influenza dem gießkannenprinzip streuen
da ist die frage lohnt es sich da bringt
das was in den kommentaren da überhaupt
zu diskutieren weil man ja da eine
fanbase auf eine fanbase trifft die
meist auch gar nicht so beeindruckend
ist da steht man dann häufig ganz
alleine
das ist immer das problem also es muss
letztendlich immer bei mir selbst
ansetzen dass ich wirklich resistent bin
dass ich wirklich war weiß wie medien zu
konsumieren sind welche medien man
konsumiert warum man welche medien
konsumiert und dass sich halt genau weiß
was seriöse quellen sind und wie ich
halt jetzt fakten lose behauptungen das
ist ja der punkt viele mythen sind ja
einfach essen oder behauptungen die man
gar nicht belegen kann dass sich die
halt wirklich von von fakten basierten
informationen unterscheiden kann
da kommt jetzt eine frage von ein paar
watt fan auf youtube die passt dazu
weshalb glauben denn so viele menschen
auch gerade wieder bei corona jetzt eine
verschwörung ich verstehe das einfach
nicht da müsste man jetzt vielleicht
noch ein psychologen mithin zu holen
aber ich mach mal laienhaft den ansatz
zum einen geht es um
informationsbedürfnisse und gefühlte
informations löcher auf der anderen
seite möchte man ja auch dass die
situation so schnell wie möglich ende da
haben wir alle ein interesse daran
und wenn dann jemand kommt und mir mit
einer einfachen lösung auf einmal etwas
bietet ich habe gestern einen
kettenbrief gelesen da hieß es die und
die stoffe würden das corona virus
bekämpfen sogar richtig erfolgreich und
wisst ihr was wohl drin die vorkommen
sind alle im café drin also kaffee wäre
die lösung das ist natürlich unsinn das
ist ein verschwörungs mythos und wenn
dann noch drunter steht das würde uns
big pharma verschweigen
dann habe ich schon wirklich alles drin
was dann so ein mythos ausmacht hier ist
eine frage von optimus prime auf youtube
kanal auf meinen rechner schalten ich
habe sie gefunden mich würde
interessieren wie die verbreitung von
fake news und verschwörungstheorien noch
mit meinungsfreiheit argumentierbar sind
kann man tatsächlich nicht sagen also
das habe ich auch öfter sollte doch mal
eine andere meinung das darf ich hier
behaupten
grundsätzlich ist sind viele sachen eine
meinung man muss halt gucken wann endet
die meinungsfreiheit und überhaupt was
ist meinungsfreiheit meinungsseite ist
er etwas will was mit der stadt
gewährleistet
unter uns privat menschen ist das völlig
wurst letztendlich wenn jemand mehr
verschickt und ich sage ich will das
nicht hören hat das ja nicht viel mit
meinungsfreiheit zu tun das ist ja an
verfallen wenn man etwas verbreitet muss
man auch immer damit rechnen dass man
ein feedback bekommen bekommt das ist
halt der punkt von social media das ist
halt das interessante an social media
ich kann jederzeit ein feedback über die
kommentare geben und das ist halt was
was von social media auch zu haben
eigentlich ganz toll demokratischen
instrument macht dass man halt über
etwas diskutieren kann und und
diskutieren soll auch also
meinungsfreiheit auf social media
bedeutet nicht dass man ohne widerrede
etwas sagen darf und alles ist gut
sondern man muss ich dem auch stellen
was man da erzählt ganz klar
letztendlich hier ist noch eine frage
auch auf youtube kann man abschalten von
alina antifa sind verschwörungen
allgemein und denkbar
das klingt mir das sicher da ich ja ich
bin noch da sobald ich hatte gerade im
monitor schwarz alles cool also die
frage wie die reptilien die mich
weggeschickt
es kommt mir nicht mit
verschwörungstheorien also die anlieger
auf youtube wissen sind den
verschwörungen allgemein undenkbar das
klingt ihr ein bisschen naiv viele
sachen anspricht wird ja auch einen
wahren kern und darauf basiert dass man
etwas hat wo man sich festmachen kann
dass man sagt okay wir haben sachen die
die stimmen habe und daraufhin etwas
aufgebaut es gibt ja so viele
verschiedene verschwörungs mieten
teilweise sind die sind die lustig
teilweise sind die wirklich ernst
teilweise sind sie auch politisch
gefährlich da muss man gucken was für
einen charakter dahinter liegt und ja da
gibt es spezifische was rauszupicken
bringt es nicht hier werden auch fragen
gestellt tatsächlich nur mit ganz
spezifischen zu verschiedenen
spezifischen menschen die sich geäußert
haben
auf youtube und anderen medien da gehen
wir jetzt nicht im detail darauf einmal
dann wird es wirklich kompliziert aber
ihr könnt die einzelnen leute googeln
und ganz viele von den behauptungen die
aufgestellt werden wurden zum beispiel
dass corinna nicht schlimmer ist als
eine grippe oder dass die maßnahmen
eingeleitet wurden um zum beispiel die
bevölkerung einzusperren
die wurden bei seriösen medien schon
aufgeklärt hat würde ich euch bitten
einfach mal zu googeln aber hier noch
mal ein interessanter kommentar also wir
haben natürlich auch viele leute die
sich jetzt gegen uns stellen hier
sorry liebe das zdf schreibt anonymous
aber dieser neu trainer bezüglich fake
news identifikation sollten die bremer
im fernsehen zu gesicht bekommen die
jugend checkt ihre fakten schon selbst
das sagst du denn dazu andre ja das
finde ich großartig denn die jugend
schickt tatsächlich ihre fakten um die
mache ich mir nämlich am wenigsten
sorgen
wir betreiben viel bildungsarbeit das
heißt wir gehen auch in die schulen der
wir und wir geben unterricht wir sind
als externe die unterricht geben und ich
mache mir um jugendlichen tatsächlich
wenig sorgen denn sie wissen dass auf
social media viele falschmeldungen
unterwegs sind sie können damit ganz
anders umgehen als eben die generation
45plus die wirklich von früher aus den
medien es gewohnt war dass die
gatekeeper funktion vorhanden war immer
und immer
auf geachtet hat dass information
richtig waren und das ist auf social
media hat nicht mehr gewährleistet ich
muss selber die gatekeeper funktion
erfüllen als nutzerin oder nutzer und
dementsprechend muss ich auch dazu in
der lage sein
also ja ich freue mich schon wenn die
jugend wie genannt selbst in zukunft
weiter aufdeckt denn die können das also
ich fast noch mal zusammen um
herauszufinden ob das stimmt oder nicht
müssen wir selber erst mal die quellen
dafür suchen wir müssen den kontext
dafür finden wir müssen gucken wer hat
was behauptet wir gucken ob das
irgendwie jemand ist er mit einem vollen
namen auftritt den man auch persönlich
anschreiben kann und wir müssen gucken
wie die geschichte erzählt wurde die uns
da präsentiert wird ob das alte
mittendrin stecken und ob das ganze
tatsächlich jetzt so sinn macht oder
nicht und dann gibt es noch ein paar
sachen haben wir euch ja gezeigt
von wegen das video wird bald gelöscht
ihr müsst das runterladen und teilen
oder es ist keine verschwörungstheorie
habe ich noch was vergessen
zusammenfassend andré vergleichen der
arbeit ist wichtig ich muss wirklich
schauen wer hat noch darüber geschrieben
an seriösen quellen was was wurde
geschrieben ich muss gucken wann wurde
zum ersten mal was veröffentlicht häufig
ist es auch ein missverständnis dass man
alte artikel neu verteilt oder auf das
datum zu gucken das ist etwas was wir
sehr häufig eingesetzt kriegen als
anfragen
letztendlich ist es auch wichtig dass
man so ein bisschen suchmaschinen kann
oder lernt wie suchmaschinen
funktionieren dass ich weiß wie ich eine
suchmaschine optimal bedienen
gleichzeitig auch eine bildersuche
beherrschen oft kriegt man bilder zu
gesendet oder videos die in einem
falschen kontext gebracht werden
das heißt mit hilfe einer bildersuche
kann ich herausbekommen wann ein bild
oder ein video zum ersten mal genutzt
wurde und dementsprechend den korrekten
kontext auch bestimmen und der letzte
punkt ist immer wenn ich nicht weiter
weiß frage ich einfach experten es gibt
zu jedem thema immer irgendwo experten
die ein gewisses fachwissen bieten die
mir helfen
so würde gerade gefragt wann wir denn
jetzt welche sachen aufkleber welche
sachen aufklären ich gebe meine seite 1
denn auf meinem rechner kurz schalten
wir haben das zum beispiel auch bei der
zdf- heute- wir haben so ein beispiel
die behauptungen von herrn südback die
auseinandergenommen die findet ihr bei
uns auf der zdf heute seite die werden
wir auch gleich noch mal in den
kommentaren packen das zum beispiel war
eines der prominenten videos die durchs
netz gegangen sind und wo wir einfach
dann geguckt haben was ist dran
das heißt wir bemühen uns auch der
aufzuklären genau wie andré wolf von
mimi kammer punkt at das heißt auch eine
adresse die wir euch empfehlen können
wenn es um die frage geht stimmt das
eigentlich was mir gerade weitergeleitet
wurde das klingt so krass dass man sich
doch nur noch mal angucken
ich danke euch für eure fragen andre für
seine zeit heute abend und hoffe ihr
werdet nicht als sub waren sind nicht
nur nächsten tagen mit den ganzen
überlegungen und faktenchecks ich danke
ein schild wünsche ich auch noch ganz
nach wien und ich sage euch vielen dank
für die ganzen kommentare und fragen die
wir hier zusammen gesammelt haben wir
sehen uns morgen wieder im nächsten
corona livestream mit eurer
sprechstunden und euren fragen und
unseren antworten tschüss bis dahin
und wenn euch der tor gefallen hat dann
guck doch mal hier rein mit einer
psychologin gesprochen die uns tipps
gibt wie wir am besten jetzt die
isolations zeit und den kontakt
kontaktsperre überstehen oder hier gibt
es ein video da hat eine
krankenschwester erzählt was die pflege
jetzt wirklich brauchten natürlich hier
unsere playlist und lasten like und ein
abo da